yes jennifer lopez and ben affleck have
found their way back to each other but
you know what yep finding a home oh
that's another story welcome to
entertainment tonight yeah y'all know
when j lo loves she cannot help but
share it and guess what we're here for
all
2.0 just engaged house hunting and
checking out this massive 165 million
dollar estate in holmby hills
the property which includes 100 parking
spaces a bowling alley and a gift
wrapping room used to be owned by 90210
and melrose place tv producer aaron
spelling and his wife candy the manor as
it's known has 27 bathrooms which is
interesting to point out since ben
proposed to jen while she was in the tub
ben even shot this bathtub video of jen
for her fans and after the proposal you
can hear him whisper
as for that 8.5 carat green diamond well
it's actually jen's sixth engagement
ring
[Music]
ben gave her a pink diamond the first
time around back in 2002 in 2004 mark
anthony proposed with a stunning blue
diamond j lo said i do to first husband
ohani noah with this pear-shaped diamond
with backup dancer chris judd it was
this emerald-cut sparkler and a-rod got
down on one knee with a 16-carat diamond
ring with all the mansion hunting and
wedding planning it might surprise you
that j-lo's about to kick off another
project today the tribeca film festival
revealed a new j-lo netflix dock
halftime it will kick off its film
festival in june the film will include
behind-the-scenes footage of j-lo
prepping for the super bowl and the
presidential inauguration
j-lo's ex-a-rod was with her for that
historic moment but his role in the dock
is unclear of course you gotta wonder
how he's been holding up with vinifer's
engagement he was teased about it sunday
night on espn2 baseball's through the
full swing
people getting engaged i mean it's a
happy time in the world it's crazy
uh happiness and the world peace is what
we're looking for you know what i think
of gandhi and you
i mean what are you going to say i want
you to tip my hat to michael k you got
to laugh
[Music]